I want to add one superfast addendum to  the video on friedel-crafts isolation in  the last step of the mechanism I had  this chlorine swiped the electron or  essentially that electron that was on  with the aluminum it was given to the  hydrogen proton so the hydrogen was  nabbed away its electron was allowed to  go back into the benzene ring so the  aluminum lost the chlorine this benzene  ring lost a proton I was able to take  back that electron and I forgot to draw  the hydrogen and the chlorine so then  that results in hydrogen chloride so you  have the hydrogen proton bonded it took  this electron from the aluminum from the  aluminum and it is bonded to the  chlorine I didn't want to forget that in  that last step of the friedel-crafts  isolation we also get some hydrogen  chloride